chantal paoli texier fondatrice
présidente d'ajc à maurepas agissez
contre la violence morale
intrafamiliales et le stocking à
l'occasion de la journée internationale
des droits des femmes dès demain vous
allez participer à l'opération et du
ministère des droits des femmes le 8
mars c'est toute l'année 365 jours
d'action l'idée justement c'est de
mobiliser tout au long de l'année et
plus uniquement une seule journée
exactement est ce que ça peut être
efficace là bas on espère parce que
c'est vrai que ne dédié qu'une journée
au droit des femmes c'est un peu dommage
et montrer fall message fort c'est quand
même montré que toute l'année c'est
l'année de l'égalité est l'année de la
lutte contre les violences faites aux
femmes
donc oui je trouve que c'est intéressant
c'est une bonne initiative et j'espère
que ça va marcher et vous allez vous
engager de quelle manière nous nous
sommes désengagés de deux manières
d'abord par l'intermédiaire de notre
parrain qui va dédier une journée de son
activité théâtrale ou cinématographique
j'accepte herman d'un réalisateur je ne
sais pas encore à
la journée de l'égalité du droit des
femmes la lutte contre les violences
conjugales et par ricochet à notre
association
et puis nous de notre côté nous avons
lancé l'idée d'une exposition événement
dont la date a été alors fou elle a été
contrarié parce qu'on avait choisi la
date anniversaire de l'association mais
malheureusement étaient déjà occupés
mais c'est pas très grave
ce sera le 3 novembre l'ouverture sera
le 3 novembre on espère que cette
exposition on pourra quand même la
maintenir au moins une semaine et non
pas rien qu'une journée mais en tout cas
il y aura une journée particulière qui
sera dédié au droit des femmes à
l'égalité dès fin mars 2013 2014 365
exactement tutelle seront qui seront
menés c'est sous l'impulsion du
gouvernement du ministère des droits des
femmes de la porte parole du
gouvernement
najat vallaud-belkacem concrètement tout
de même on a le sentiment que c'est une
belle opération de communication
est-ce que ça va servir véritablement
aussi à des victimes peut-être pour
qu'elles se manifestent parce que je
parle d'opération de communication il ya
aussi un site internet qui va avait donc
c'est très très bien voilà ce que oui
parce que parce que ça c'est un truc
c'est utile pour ces victimes qui moi on
pense qu'on ne parle pas suffisamment de
la problématique
par exemple ce qui nous concerne nous en
tant qu'association c'est la lutte
contre les violences conjugales et je
trouve qu'on n'en parle pas suffisamment
les par exemple les campagnes qui sont
faites pour la lutte
ll ne sont diffusés que très très peu
autour du 8 mars et pis c'est tout et je
trouve que c'est regrettable parce que
c'est toute l'année qu'il faut lutter
contre ces violences mais c'est toute
l'année aussi qu'il faut lutter pour
l'égalité des femmes et des hommes et
pour la parité
donc ça va paralyser moi je pense vers
journée internationale est vraiment je
pense pas je pense que encore une fois
le 8 mars est une date intéressante
c'est comme un anniversaire oui je
j'entends bien que ça permet aux médias
de se focaliser sur cette période là
mais moi je trouve ça dommage parce que
nous on est là à pied d'oeuvre tous les
jours trois strange case il faut 500
fans tous les jours mais ça fait rien ce
sera ça sera ponctuelle et je pense que
l'élu l'idée c'est que c'est qu'on dise
c'est que le message passe que ben voilà
il faut tous les jours y penser en tout
cas le 8 mars c'est toute l'année
l'opération sera lancée demain soir au
palais des congrès de la cité des
sciences à paris sur le plan législatif
c'est l'autre volet au delà de l'aspect
communication événements qui sont
organisées en mai prochain à l'assemblée
dans une loi cadre sur le droit des
femmes
elle regroupera plusieurs axes de
travail tels que les questions d'égalité
professionnelle du statut et des femmes
étrangères installées sur le territoire
français aussi élu tu es violence et
puis la question de la parité qui sera
bien évidemment abordés dans cette
loi-cadre vous en attendez quoi nous on
en attend une application déjà de la loi
du 9 juillet c'est à dire
une réponse à certaines parties de la
loi du 9 juillet 2010 qui n'avaient pas
été prises en compte comme par exemple
les formations des professionnels le
droit des femmes s'intéressent beaucoup
à ce sujet là donc on espère que c'est
ça va être abordé en maintenant la loi
cadre
je crois que voilà il faut pas non plus
trop de voir enfin moi j'suis pas non
plus pour démultiplier les lois parce
qu'après on en subit les conséquences
ceci dit le cadre législatif actuel est
plein de trous dans lesquels
s'engouffrent les auteurs de violences
morales et c'est vrai que je pense qu'il
faut réfléchir à ça et qu'il ya
peut-être des solutions à apporter nous
en tout cas on a apporté dans notre
livre dans le livre qui sort de ma très
belle transition la violence morale au
quotidien des mots semblent eu des mots
qui tuent oui tout est fait pour de
votre ouvrage avec aj c'est là votre
association
oui c'est l'éditeur guy trédaniel les
six éditions j lionla yonne je ne sais
pas comment ça se dit en fait et cet
ouvrage qui est un vraiment exhaustif
qui qui revisite toute la violence mans
à tous les aspects de la violence morale
de à tous les niveaux
y compris sociologique presque même si
nous ne sommes pas des sociologues fait
la part belle sur tout l'aspect
psychologique la prise en charge et
partie juridique très importante c'est
la partie la plus lourde que je veux
mener au quotidien d'être et votre
association apporte donc nous avons eu
un regard critique que nous avons
développée par sur sur tout ce chapitre
qui a le chapitre le plus long et
ensuite nous avons fait des
préconisations à la fin du livre et nous
espérons fortement que ces
préconisations seront prises en compte
par nos politiques vous intervenez sur
le domaine des violences morales domaine
qui concerne le couple 1 c'est souvent
dans ce domaine là que ça s'exprime le
plus souvent on voit des images de vos
locaux justement peut-être rappeler
combien de personnes vous accueillez le
travail que vous menez quotidiennement
alors si c'est difficile d'évaluer le
nombre de personnes qu'on accueille
parce qu'entre les permanences les mails
les permanences téléphoniques les mails
et puis les entretiens c'est les
chiffres ne me viennent pas là mais
cette année c'est vrai qu'on a battu
tous les records en 2012 et en 2013 mais
en 2012 on a battu tous les records
qu'est ce qu'il explique je pense qu'on
en parle beaucoup plus on revient vers
les victimes voilà les médias en parlent
les médias analyse et du coup la parole
se libère et du coup les victimes
viennent nous voir
par contre le phénomène que nous
enregistrons c'est c'est pas tant la
quantité c'est la la la lourdeur des
dossiers que nous que nous accompagnons
actuellement c'est vrai que si on se
retrouve face à des difficultés
juridiques comme on en n'avait encore
jamais rencontrés le plus difficile pour
une victime c'est de savoir surtout à
quel moment parlé de harcèlement moral
comment le détecter on va continuer à
échanger avec vous a parlé de votre
ouvrage également donc apparaître dès
demain on va revoir la couverture la
violence morale au quotidien des mots
semblent des mots qui tuent auparavant
un micro trottoir quand parler de
harcèlement moral nous sommes allez vous
poser la question comment déceler à
partir de quel moment on bascule dans la
violence pense qu'il ya pas il n'y a pas
un harcèlement moral
je pense que chaque situation est unique
après c'est à gérer au cas par cas
actuellement m'ont dit pas bonjour tout
simplement pas le moment où on rentre
dans un quelque part on dit pas bonjour
c'est ignorer c'est commencer avec
harcèlement je parle bien sûr dans le
milieu professionnel entre autres
quoique mouillé du chantage fin qu on
demande quelque chose en échange
d'autres choses ça commence quand ça
devient pesant pour la personne qui est
harcelée c'est là que ça commence alors
les moyens ils peuvent être tellement
multiples et divers les paroles
s'envolent les paroles terribles même
c'est bon c'est pas des injures ce sont
des paroles qui vous qui vous rendre la
vie impossible pour moi c'est quelque
chose d'impensable mais bon
malheureusement ça arrive on s'en fait
que les gens sont effectivement
sensibiliser sur ces différentes
questions par de paroles mais quelles
sont ses paroles qu'elles sont les les
mots qu'ils font les montants des
rigoles ans les mots qui tuent les mots
qui tuent oui oui mais la parole c'est
le seul outil majeur de tous les auteurs
de violences morales c'est c'est leur
façon de jouer avec les mots alors
effectivement c'est peut-être des
insultes ça peut être des menaces mais
c'est pas que ça c'est l'enseignement
aussi claire g du tout c'est plutôt la
double injonction c'est plutôt la double
contrainte c'est plutôt très très
insidieux et très jaillir furtif c'est
le mot qui me vient à l'esprit mais si
ça en fin de compte c'est subliminal
voilà ça crée une espèce d'hypnose et d'
état de sidération chez la victime
et quand la victime pas le détecter
alors c'est difficile quand lyon un
moment elle seule un master va trop loin
voilà moi je dirais que si on était
mieux connecter à notre cerveau
reptilien et donc à notre instinct on
entendrait les petits signaux d'alarmé
parce que toutes les victimes nous
disent qu'elles ont entendu des signaux
d'alarmé qu'elles n'ont pas voulu y
prêter attention parce que parce qu'elle
était dans une période de fascination de
damour enfin en majuscules parce qu'elle
prenait pour de l'amour parce qu'elle
avait l'impression d'avoir rencontré le
prince charmant or le prince charmant
n'existe pas
soyons clairs c'est pas une révélation
ce soir mais c'est pas la paix mais je
pense qu on ne le dira jamais assez
parce que les jeunes filles continue
quand même à rêver à sa et les jeunes
jambes aussi d'ailleurs parce que c'est
pareil les princesses n'existe pas non
plus la solution mais internationale des
droits des femmes mais soyons mais
soyons leur valeur comptable la parité
les auteurs de violences morales sont
autant des hommes que des femmes
oui et ça on en parle moins mais c'est
une réalité tout à fait aux mêmes
proportions d'ailleurs alors lâche on
peut pas donner des proportions parce
que si on se fie à notre association qui
accueillons autant aux hommes femmes que
enfin un adolescent ça fait 20 % pour
2012 c'est vrai qu'on a nos chiffres ont
augmenté jusqu'à présent ça toujours été
10% là brusquement et passer à 20%
ça veut dire peut-être que les hommes
justement prennent plus conscience et
puis font plus de démarches mais c'est
vrai que les hommes ont beaucoup
d'hommes victimes
attention les hommes victimes ont
beaucoup plus de difficultés à faire des
démarches et a parlé de l'amour propre
ce déficit c'est la moins pire hop c'est
une certaine fierté c'est avouer qu'on
est victime savait la démarche de
s'avouer qu'on est victime autant pour
une femme que pour un homme elle est
très très compliqué elle est difficile
parce que ça ne leur correspond pas si
c'est vrai que ça ne correspond qu'à un
temps de leur vie c'est à dire quand on
leur dit ça ça les rassure mais
mais c'est infinitésimal quoi ça va pas
être toute leur vie et pour un homme
c'est quelque chose de beaucoup plus
difficile à a avoué à s'avouer à soi
même que l'on a été effectivement
victime d'une prédatrice et de toute
cette violence morale vous en parlait
dans l' ouvrage la violence morale au
quotidien des mots semblent des mots qui
tuent dans ce livre également vous
donner des conseils
oui s'adresse autant aux victimes qu'aux
professionnels
on a voulu
on a voulu essayer d'être le plus large
possible donc on donne des conseils
effectivement victime mais on donne
aussi des indications en professionnel
pour pouvoir assurer une meilleure prise
en charge de la violence morale et donc
on a un regard critique aussi sur
l'actuelle prise en charge de la
violence morale parce qu'on a encore
beaucoup beaucoup de difficultés à
traiter cette violence pour ce qu'elle
est c'est-à-dire comme dit karen sadlier
qui a assuré la préface de notre ouvrage
la colonne vertébrale de toutes les
formes de violence on a encore beaucoup
trop tendance à la considérer comme une
violences légères
moi ça me hérisse ça ne peut pas être
une violences légères
c'est une violence à part entière et qui
détruit le fondement même de l'être
humain
donc on peut imaginer ce que ça veut
dire quand ça détruit la dignité la
capacité à être à exister et à agir et
on vous invite donc à découvrir cet
ouvrage juste pour conclure un dernier
mot sur votre parent peut être on l'a
évoqué tout à l'heure un sam karmann
l'acteur de cinéma de théâtre de
télévision aussi réalisateur il est mort
passe bien il habite sur la ville de
mortalité votre association
ils vous aident au quotidien moment là
c'est que vous venez souvent sorti la
mairie non non non il peut pas c'est pas
possible c'est pas possible non son
travail de parent c'est c'est 2 à
l'occasion de pouvoir participer à une
manifestation dédiée à quelques minutes
de son temps
voilà mon ce qu'il accepte très
volontiers de faire mais en même temps
bon c'est quand même quelqu'un qui
travaille beaucoup énormément donc non
non il peut pas au quotidien nous
accompagner par contre il est tenu au
courant de tout ce que nous faisons et
de toutes nos avancées et quand il peut
nous donner un conseil il n'hésite pas
il sera le bienvenu sur ce plateau
la prochaine fois on viendrait avec lui
chantal paoli tessier vous serez demain
présente à paris pour le lancement du 8
mars c'est toute l'année ministère des
droits des femmes qui souhaitent et que
chacun s'engage à mener une action
chaque jour de l'année ce sera en
novembre pour vous on aura l'occasion
d'en reparler
tout ça pour en finir avec les violences
les inégalités dans un instant de
parleront aux cultures sur cette antenne
la page culture pour l'instant nous
partons à plaisir dans le quartier du
val ibuka récit en cours de rénovation
pour éviter les tags sur les bâtiments
une idée originale le principe des
fresques participative les explications
de julie rocha soirée celle de guillaume
cance impliquer les habitants pour
préserver le quartier valley bout de
plaisir la ville espère mettre fin ou
dégradations qui touchent déjà les 2 139
logements réhabilités il y a un nom
selon un concept unique en ile de france
des fresques participative réalisé sur
plusieurs années par citécréation
spécialiste de l'art mural reconnu dans
le monde entier
effectivement on pense avoir trouvé une
super idée qui est une idée de remise en
état en tout cas visuel de ce quartier
pour lui redonner une identité par le
biais de certains artistes qui ont d'un
grand talent et qui depuis 35 ans
agissant des quartiers pas uniquement
pour mettre des fresques comme ça
histoire de faire joli et pour avoir
tout un travail de fond avec les
habitants du quartier
ces derniers devront expliquer ce qui
caractérise leur quartier pour que la
coopérative d'artistes retranscrivent
ses idées sur les murs sous la forme de
trompe l'oeil saynètes aux couleurs
vives ou personnages emblématiques du
quartier et modification des
comportements sur ces liens sont très
forts dans la mesure où les gens sont
fiers entre de la dignité parce qu'on
vient les voir
si on vient les voir c'est qu'ils
n'habitent pas n'importe où mais s'ils
veulent importer ou c'est qu'ils sont
pas n'importe qui
et du coup on remonte comme ça d'un cran
et on se redresse de quelques
centimètres
certains sites deviennent même
incontournables comme le quartier bel
air de chartres on a évidemment cette
cathédrale qui est magnifique que tout
le monde connaît mais le quartier de
l'air fait aussi partie maintenant des
endroits qu'on va visiter parce qu'on
est à 3500 mètres carrés de fresques
qu'ils sont qui sont qui sont pas vous
avez la boulangère qui est parent la
petite fille qui habite du car est du
quartier qui est peint sur le mur
donc tout ça fait partie sous les dunes
contribution totale des habitants à la
réalisation de ce projet et ils se
sentent considérés des fresques qui
développe le tourisme mais aussi des
vocations professionnelles puisque les
jeunes peuvent s'initier aux métiers
porteurs de peintres muralistes à
plaisir le bailleur social l'eau pied
voix a acté le principe de la fresque
le projet sera défini en conseil
d'administration au mois d'avril
restera ensuite à consulter les quatre
mille plaisirs voies concernées
il faut deux de temps il faut les
sensibiliser faut les montrer aussi de
le poser comment comment on doit faire
qu'est ce que ça va donner la place aux
autres m'ont posé des questions sur
aucune augmentation de loyer n'est
envisagée en attendant la concrétisation
du projet la deuxième partie du chantier
de réhabilitation du vélib ou qui porte
sur 450 logements devrait être finalisée
d'ici fin 2013